hey guys it's dr. Berg here in this
video I'm going to show you how to
prevent a fatty liver when you try to
lose weight on your diet okay I'm going
to use this little book to show you a
reference a textbook on medical
physiology this is the Bible of medical
physiology this is very interesting I
found this quote here and let me read
this to you effective insulin Lac on
causing a fatty liver strange as it may
seem though insulin Lac causes
disillusion which is the breaking down
of something of the fat stores in
adipose tissue it causes a great
increase in the amount of stored
triglycerides in the liver leading to a
very fatty liver Wow what does that mean
that means that when you lower your
insulin and you start burning a lot of
fat you're at risk of making your liver
fatty because all that fat has to go
through the body but there's two things
that I want to talk about so what
happens you go on an eating plan and
you're lowering insulin okay if you
watch some my other videos on insulin we
want to lower that thing down way down
there so that's avoiding this sugars we
want to avoid eating so many meals and
grazing and snacking and all that so
cause this fat cell to dissolve and then
the fat goes to your blood and ends up
in the liver okay there's two things
you're going to do to prevent this from
happening number one you have to there's
no way around it you have to keep the
vegetables in your diet high and that's
why I always recommend at least
minimally every single day 7 cups of
vegetables because even the Atkins diet
they don't emphasize it's all this high
protein but then they don't emphasize
the vegetable and some other diets don't
even recommend vegetables they keep it
low like ideal protein well what's going
to happen you're going to end up with
the final liver because we need the
vegetable to clean that liver to pose
all the fats that that's coming out of
out of you so we want vegetable
we don't want corn we want leafy greens
okay not just from a powder but actual
salads and
so you're going to have to figure that
out now you can drink your salad and
account shake if you want but we need
the vegetable okay so that's number one
number two apple cider vinegar
what's an apple cider vinegar apple
cider vinegar is really really really
good for the liver and the help dissolve
a fatty liver and clean it up there are
other supplements that you can take like
choline for example that also are good
for a fatty liver and that's the type of
B vitamin and believe it or not guess
what food has the highest choline egg
yolks interesting right lecithin is
another thing you consume to dissolve
the fatty liver and guess what I have as
high lecithin egg yolks so egg yolk is
actually a really good thing to consume
and because what'll happen if you do
that your body will then make less
cholesterol because there's cholesterol
in the egg yolk so your liver makes
about 2,000 milligrams a day so if you
eat a little bit more egg your body just
makes less so egg yolks are totally okay
so we want vegetable we want egg yolks
and we definitely want apple cider
vinegar 2 tablespoons and a glass of
water three times a day ok so that's
just an important tip as you do your
program to prevent if I liver and also
how do you know if you have a fatty
liver well if your belly is big you have
a fatty liver okay but if you want to
prevent a fatty liver go ahead and keep
the vegetables in it all the time all
right see the next video